calamari cardinals quarterback
trying to end a three-game losing streak
would be a five-game losing streak but
for the hail murray play which
really didn't do much to to turn this
team
into the high-end contender we thought
they were going to become
and now a game that we would have looked
at chris
several weeks you all right there what
you got going on
you know hoodie just getting straight
there yeah
i just i wondered i didn't know whether
you were performing some sort of surgery
on your
neck uh with you know without the
benefit of anesthesia i didn't know what
was going on anyway
uh this game a few weeks ago we looked
at it and said
[Music]
cardinals giants now all of a sudden
it's got some significance and you could
argue the giants have
a better path to the postseason because
they're tied for first place and they
hold the tiebreaker over washington in
the nfc east at five and seven yeah so
what's more likely
in this cardinals giants game kyler
murray has
50 plus rushing yards or the giants have
three or more sacks murray has three
straight games
with 31 or fewer rush yards chris
yeah um i'm going to go
with the giants have three plus sacks
here i am i'm gonna say they get the
three
or maybe more listen it's hard
maybe recency biased but again
the formula is out there and
new england coaches have played kyler
murray already this year
and guess what we got new england
coaches playing kyler murray once again
i just have a hard time not that it's
gonna be like oh man what a pass rush by
the new york giants
i think a lot of it's gonna be like what
we saw last week with the seattle
seahawks playing the giants
russell wilson's gonna drop back and be
like whoa
nobody's freaking open hold on wait
would somebody come open nope and then
all of a sudden it's going to collapse
and he's going to get sacked and it's
going to be that type of thing i think
it's going to be more out of
keeping him contained but more out of
whoa nobody's open
and i'm confused a little and then get
sacked i think you're going to see a lot
of that
i i think there's a difference though
from the seahawks game to this game
because
the seahawks may have stepped into a
trap the seahawks may have not taken the
shot
seriously and i don't think the
cardinals especially after what
the giants did to the seahawks i don't
think the cardinals are going to do that
i think the best thing for the cardinals
to get themselves ready
for this game was that the giants beat
the seahawks because now the cardinals
are not
going to to think that that they're the
team that should easily win
that they know it's going to be a fight
and they may not have known that
if the giants hadn't just beaten the
seahawks sure yeah i i hear you there
all right so with all that what are you
saying you think it's going to be
50-plus yards or three plus sacks
i i think that i have a hard time
imagining
kyler murray losing four straight games
i i we need to look at the 2019 schedule
to see if at any point they lost four
games i remember at one point they lost
three in a row
and that was like a match of his
total college and high school losses
yeah together
well he was very close losing five in a
row right this year so like oh i know
i know yeah i know but but so so five
out of six
it'll be if they lose this one i just i
feel like he's going to find a way to
rise up
and and overcome this giants team and if
that means getting 50 or more russian
yards along the way so be it so i think
it's more likely to have 50 or more
rushing yards okay how about the 11-1
chiefs now back at the top of the pft
power rankings which is far more
important than winning a super bowl
at the miami dolphins eight and four and
the chiefs possibly peaking ahead
to the week 15 showdown against the new
orleans saints what's more likely
patrick mahomes
throws an interception in the game or
dolphins quarterback tuatanga viloa
throws his first
career nfl interception well i i'll say
the first thing i'll say is that the
chiefs better not like take this lightly
they better not
because this this dolphins team matches
up very well with them
okay in a lot of ways and this dolphins
team with brian flores again we know
being from new england
no they know they know how to defend
patrick mahomes and tyree kill and
company and all that
i really want to say i think we could
see both here
i would think with hey these corners and
this secondary in miami with that
coaching of flores and all that that
they give my homes and company a few
moments of you know
not driving the ball being confused
maybe not looking great
i would think that happens tonight but
or on sunday but
i think if you're going to make me pick
one i'm going to go with two of throws
his first career interception i think
that
that would make sense to me i guess i
guess what i think is
the chiefs can apply early pressure that
might make tua and company have to throw
the ball a little bit more than they'd
like
and then this is a defense that does a
lot of different stuff in kansas city
and gives you some crazy looks it could
be hard on a rookie quarterback so i'll
i'll play that angle here
yeah i'll agree with you even though the
dolphins have an
interception in nine of the last ten
games not shooting four
straight they haven't faced patrick
mahomes who barely
throws interceptions and has been very
careful with the football this year
tua hasn't seen a defense like the
chiefs
in that you've got the versatility on
the back and it's it's a good
smooth blend level to level
you know there isn't one area that jumps
out it's just a
solid balanced defense we saw what they
did on sunday night to the denver
broncos
and i think it's more likely that we
finally see an interception from tua
with each passing week there's more film
there's more film there's more film
and and steve spagnuolo and company
cracking a code and maybe
maybe giving him a look and confusing
and making him think something's there
yeah and then there comes tyrant matthew
to grab the football and that's that
the vikings six and six at the rested
tampa bay buccaneers seven and five
a sneaky huge game especially if the
vikings should find a way to upset the
buccaneers i don't
see that happening frankly i don't want
to tip too much of my picks coming up
later today but what's more likely in
this when dalvin cook
has over 120 rushing yards or under 70
and we pose that because
he's averaging 113.6 rush yards
per game that leads the league and tampa
bay
is allowing 74.2 rush yards per game
that leads the league as well so
something's got to give in this one
chris which one is more likely 120
or under 70. ah man that's i mean
galvin cook has reached like you know
unstoppable force
phase like basically as a runner he
really has i mean
it's it's hard to envision him not
getting
a hundred or close to it bye week
buccaneers secondary you know young
talented i don't know i don't think the
vikings offensive pass formula
is all that complicated i'm gonna go if
you're gonna make me pick one of these
i'm going
i'm going under 70. i'm gonna do that i
am i just think the buccaneers are gonna
sell out to stop dalvin cook
and just go hey the same thing we don't
think the pass game and kirk cousins and
everything's going to beat us today
as long as we take dalvin cook away i
think that'll be an approach and they
have the bodies of big people up front
to do that
you know back in 1998 randy moss's
rookie season the only regular season
loss for the vikings came
at tampa bay there would be some poetry
in it if justin jefferson
the best vikings rookie receiver since
randy moss and one of the best rookie
receivers we've seen
frankly for any team since randy moss if
he could go down there
and be the difference maker if they do
sell out to stop the run
and kirk cousins starts firing it in
justin jefferson's direction
and they can't stop him that that may be
the only way the vikings can pull this
off chris yeah i
mean it could be it might have to be
i i could very easily envision it being
okay and domicansou and jpp and
everybody
slow down dalvin cook and yeah i mean if
the vikings want to make it happen
they should get some opportunities
against you know carlton i mean carlton
davis and those corners down there to go
hey here's justin jefferson double move
one on one downfield
they have become more dangerous that way
your vikings football team
as the year has gone on and kirk cousins
you know we probably don't talk about
him quite enough
i mean the big throws throws you know
degree of difficulty throws you know
kirk cousins is phenomenal that way i
mean
every week we watch them throw deep
posts and post
corners and 25 yard crossers and
20 yard in cuts and they're on the money
you know he i don't see a whole lot of
like
four and five and eight easy you know
eight yard easy completions forum
it's like it's screen to dalvin cook or
we're gonna throw a 30 yard completion
there's no in middle ground with them
and
you know that's hard to play that way
but they do it and they do it
effectively
and you know there's a people are
comparing justin jefferson to randy moss
randy moss
that one of the year it was deep ball
deep ball deep ball deep ball justin
jefferson's all over the place he's
making every catch on the route tree he
can do it all
he's taking a lot of contact too but uh
he has gotten better
and better and better and better and i
just think if they're gonna have any
chance it this may not be a dalvin cook
game this may be a
justin jefferson rival yeah game
i think that's it i do i i mean i'm with
you i i look at it like
for for the vikings if they want to win
the game it's almost gonna have to be
like you know their bears game a few
weeks ago when they played where yeah we
ran the ball
it wasn't great but just effective
enough to keep them worried about the
run
to where now we think kirk cousins and
company can make a few plays in the past
game
if they can make those plays and kirk
cousins you know we look up at the end
of the day and go man kirk cousins has
got you know
320 330 yards pass and maybe they're in
this football game
uh maybe they are but i don't know do
you think that your vikings defense can
stop
tommy and all those weapons no yeah no
no
no and no we'll talk more about that
later today
in the pft pm chris sims on button
megapixel cast but uh for now
i'll just say no cults eight and four at
raiders seven and five
what's more likely ty hilton has a
hundred plus
receiving yards or darren waller the
great tight end
of the las vegas raiders does last week
hilton had his first 100
yard receiving game since 2018 when
andrew luck was the quarterback and
darren waller had
200 receiving yards sixth all time
by any nfl tight end uh this is a
i mean pete's done a good job of making
these tough here
uh t.y hilton certainly looks good and
like back to a hundred percent himself
that was the houston texans defense last
night last week though
and they're pretty crappy as far as pass
defense is concerned
you know the raiders on the other hand
will get in your face can cover you
man-to-man don't give you a lot of easy
throws
i know damon damon arnett you know he
came out of the game last week
i don't know what his status was i think
he got a concussion um
but i think in this one i'm going with
darren waller
i'm gonna go darren waller has the big
day
i guess last year's game the raiders
colts
still comes to my mind a little bit you
know the raiders with that big offensive
line
and what they do the colts not like the
biggest defensive line deforest
buckner's big but it's not a huge d
line it's about a little bit more speed
and movement and chaos and doing that
type of stuff
i could see oakland giving them issues
running the ball
and then leaving darren waller wide open
for play action behind it and those type
of matchups so
i'm going to go with waller here yeah
i'm going to agree with you i mean just
because
ty hilton had one 100 yard receiving
game
for the first time in two years that
doesn't make me think that all of a
sudden he's going to be racking him up
left and right i mean waller was just
flat out dominant and maybe some of that
dominance trickles over
into this week i still i yeah i don't
want to tip too many of my picks
i know that's what i don't like about
these segments i feel like we talk too
much you get too much information
steelers 11-1 at buffalo nine and three
on sunday night football what's more
likely the pittsburgh defense
has two or more interceptions or josh
allen has
three or more total touchdowns what's
more like how dare you disrespect my boy
blue pete demilitas
i mean how dare you to think he would
throw two plus interceptions what are
you doing
um no this is that could very easily
happen we know the pittsburgh defense
and what they can create on that side of
the ball
but i'm gonna go with josh allen in the
three plus total tds i
am i don't expect it to be four or five
or anything like that
but i think three is a very realistic
number with the way he can play
the way he can run extend plays and and
make things happen in the red zone or
far outside the red zone yeah i
i think they can't i still have
questions with steelers against this
type of team this is why i've talked
about with them where i just don't think
they can beat the kansas city chiefs
this will be a big
you know eye test to just see how they
match up to an explosive offense that's
got a good system
and a quarterback who can take over
games josh allen has gotten to that
that category as we've seen so when we
saw last week pittsburgh
when the pass rush dies out all of a
sudden alex smith there's people
open everywhere and that's what i worry
about pittsburgh going forward so you're
going to make me pick one of the other
i'm going to go with josh allen three
tds
we know we talked about this earlier in
the week i look at what josh allen did
to the 49ers defense and i can see a
similar thing happening to the
pittsburgh defense and i'm going to
agree with you even though the steelers
lead the league with 16
interceptions and josh allen your boy
blue yeah has made bills fans blue a
couple of times this year with two
interceptions right
i just don't see it happen in this game
i just think the bills
are in the process of peaking at the
right time right first glimpse of it is
what we saw on monday night they're
getting these
prime time games and nationally
televised games they got an nfl network
doubleheader coming up
saturday the 19th uh where where they're
playing in the afternoon
there's there's an edge about people get
to see them right people get to see them
down the home stretch and
and they kind of like that we're back
remember the the fourth year of the
bill's super bowl run it was basically
deal with it they're kind of getting
that deal with it attitude
we're sick of hearing about the steelers
and the chiefs and they get a chance to
do something about it as it relates to
the pittsburgh steelers
all right uh plenty of good stuff there
and again we will be
making picks in every week 14 game
coming up later today
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports